Thank You mr. president I have two
questions for you one is this that's
more you totally speaking with the g20
leaders and I want to know if you're
gonna lead an effort to craft a
wolf-like ban on wild animal market so
as to prevent another pandemic given the
mid-nineteen is a zoonotic that was
transferred to humans in trade of exotic
Adam yeah I don't know that that subject
should have come up there is a lot of
talk that that's how this all happened
came out of China and they say that's
how it happened in China so it's
something maybe will be talked about but
it's not the top of my list and also a
dr. Hershey shop who's the head of
Harvard's Global Health Institute says
the key to getting this economy open as
soon as possible is to test everyone who
needs testing so we can quarantine all
infected individuals and allow everyone
else to go back to work immediately
would you subscribe to that strategy no
but I we have tested more than anybody I
saw and if not how many deaths are
acceptable yeah
how many none okay how many deaths are
acceptable to me and none okay none if
that's your question